♪ Щедрий вечір, добрий вечір, добрим людям ... ♪
— Хто знає точно щедрівку?
— Я знаю щедрівку...
Хай тебе слухають усі!...
Перепишіть і все...
[гомонять між собою]
Повій вітер буйнесенький, суши фартух тонесенький...
Треба ще сказати, що танці були спеціальні, чоловічі, на Маланки.
Самі чоловіки танцювали там.
Так як опрешки коло ватри, так це з Маланкою танцювати.
Перепрошую...
Потім прийдеш, ти розумієш, я знаю,
що ти хочеш посіяти, але потім.
Посіяти...
Маланка тут ніби законсервована.
Бо в 1944 році на Покрову було проголошено Космацьку самостійну республіку військами УПА.
І КГБ тут не пустили ні науковців, нікого.
Всіх арештували, і тут все збереглося таким, яким воно було.
[грає жива народна музика]
Маланки в Космачі не було.
У Космачі називався обряд Маланкування — Щідрівники.
Вони щідрували. Щідра була, а не Коляда.
Щедрівка там на Вкраїні: на Слобожанщині, на Покутті, на Поділлі, а у Космачі була Щідра.
Це був невеликий театр, кожен мав свою роль.
Хоча, на відміну від українського Вертепу,
там не було специфічних слів.
Ні для Кози, ні для Ведмедя,
ні для Смерті, ні для кого не було.
Була загальна щедрівка, яку всі співали разом.
Вона мала побажальний зміст:
Побажати господарям, щоб в них був добрий урожай,
щоб в них коровки, овечки потелилися, покотилися.
Щоб в них був прибуток і бджоли добре роїлися, і так далі...
[народний спів]
Головними персонажами Космацької Маланки
були Маланка і Василь.
Василь уособлював у собі місяць, а Маланка — воду.
Дід і Баба — це є друга пара.
Циган і Циганка.
Крім того було багато нечистої сили: Люципери, Арідники.
Була Коза, був Ведмідь.
З роками дія Маланки і Василя у Космачі видозмінилася.
Замість Василя зробився Князь, замість Маланки — Княгиня.
Звісна річ, що все тече, усе минає.
Додаються нові персонажі.
Давай гроші, давай, давай...
[сміються]
Традиційна Маланка мала своє завдання.
Вони мали музикантів з собою.
Вони ходили хатами у той спосіб,
що вони не оминали ні бідного, ні багатого.
Якщо взяти Космацьких колядників:
коли підходили до господаря на подвір'я,
то вони сповіщали трембітою, що вони йдуть.
Якщо взяти Космацьку Маланку, то  всякі нечисті
сили [персонажі] мали на собі цілу купу колоколів.
І тими колоколами колотали,
щоби було чути, що вони вже йдуть.
І в кожну хату, коли вони йшли,
то під хатою питалися [дозволу].
Можна защедрувати?
І тільки тоді, коли господарі казали,
що можна — вони йшли щедрувати.
♪ Щедрий вечір, щедрівочка, прилетіла ластівочка ♪
♪ Стала щебетати, зранку спати не давати... ♪
У багатьох щедрівках підкреслюється, що Маланка це є чоловік.
«На ній сорочка парубоча», — співають.
У Космачі це були суто чоловіки, жінок там не було.
Казали, що якби там була жінка, то був би рік «порожній».
І там були тільки чоловіки, але вони виконували різні ролі.
Маланка — це в деякій мірі як радість,
це розвеселяє душу.
Розвеселяє все, що є навколо.
Мене звати Іван, я з села Космач.
Я житель цього села і ми
знаходимось на присілку Ведмежому.
І на цім присілку зібрали цих хлопців і дітей,
які пришли зі мною і підтримали мене,
і підтримали цю традицію — нашу Маланку.
З малечі зберу цю Маланку...
Многая літ! Щастя і здоров'я!
З малечі — чому я хотів, щоб саме діти йшли в Маланку.
Щоб не забути цю традицію ніколи.
Чому? Бо старші в деякій мірі почали не хотіти  ходити.
Не знаю яка причина, чи то гроші, чи то будь-що.
Я думаю, нехай це буде започатковуватися з маленьких дітей.
Щоб їм призвичаїти саме цю традицію,
щоб вони хотіли теж виконувати цю традицію.
За Радянських часів не можна було колядувати,
це було заборонено, але люди ходили.
А зараз, коли все дозволено, то люди не йдуть,
от що, я не знаю чому.
♪ За воротами ватра горить, Маланочка рибку варить. ♪
♪ Присунувся старий міський, як сунь, так сунь рибку з миски ♪
♪ Ой, царю-чоботарю не для тебе рибку варю ♪
♪ А я варю для Івана.
В нього личко, як у пана. ♪
У Маланки маски є цікаві.
Ці маски виготовлялися вручну.
Якщо українські інші етнічні землі мали слово маска,
то у Космачі маска називалася «наличмани».
Тому що та маска, коли одягнена, то не видно людини.
Ті наличмани шили переважно із овечих чи козячих шкір.
Цікаво, що не всі щедрувальник
мають бажання, аби їх впізнали.
Навіть буває так що, коли вони їдять,
то вони стараються так їсти, аби їх менше впізнавали.
Маланка, коли почастувалася у тій хаті,
де збиралася, тоді вона вирушає в інші хати.
І щедрують аж до самого ранку.
Кажіть: «Дякуємо файно та бувайте здорові, з Новим Роком вас! Щастя, здоров'я вам!»
— Говоріть!
— Німі Маланки...
З Новим Роком поздоровляйте!
Що це за Маланка така?
З Новим Роком вас.
Щастя, здоров'я вам!
Жінок не було у Маланці, чому?
Тому що там було багато таких бешкетливих дій.
Не кожна жінка на таке б згодилася.
Тим більше що завдання було у Маланці
трохи наробити комусь збитків.
Помучати жінок: поперевертати, у снігу покачати,
помастити сажею, попелом і так далі.
Завжди Маланка мала сажу, міх із попелом.
Ним могли побити кого завгодно.
І коли закінчували щедрівку цю,
через два тижні, через три збиралися у того,
хто збирав усіх щедрівників вдома
і робили «розщідру» або «гілепчину».
Розщідра — це фінал цього дійства.
І передавали іншому, хто має
брати наступному року, цих щедрівників.
Маланка — це не є Коляда, ні Вертеп,
де має бути все серйозно, все стримано, поважно.
Це є розвага, мінікарнавал.
Я вважаю, що Україна може зробити
карнавал ані трохи не гірший.
Тільки треба, щоб наша влада, від гори до долини,
більше думала про культуру і мистецтво.
Про традиції і звичаї, і не було би війни,
і не було би біди усюди.
Бо люди мали б якесь заняття.